okay
yeah at the last session and uh it's
good that we will now hear something
about mendelian
vectorization actually
so much about
[Music]
from here
[Music]
and thank you the organizer for this
organization of the session
um
i'm afraid i don't know much about the
backgrounds of the audience so i try my
best to explain
and if you have any questions feel free
to stop me at any time
and today i'm going to talk about
breaking the winner's curse in mendelian
randomization or maybe just a quick
introduction of myself
i am an assistant professor of
biostatistics at here at uc berkeley in
the school of public health and this is
a joint work with my collaborators ching
wenma he is an econometrician in uc san
diego and also chong wu from florida
state university
since i'm going to talk about medina
randomization i want to show you this
has been a very popular thing in
epidemiology
this is the
this is the record con i extract earlier
this year so you can see the record cons
from the web of signs from mendelian
randomization has been increasing over
the past few the past decade
so what really is mendelian
randomization
uh so i'll start my talk with
introducing what is mendelian
randomization and what mendelian
randomization can do for us
so this is a plot i want to investigate
the effect of smoking a life expectancy
if you only look at the associations
between whether you smoke and how long
you can live it looks like smokers tend
to die younger
it's definitely looked that way but is
there any causal associations between
these two factors we do not really know
because there are many factors hinders
our understanding between these two
vectors
well for example
there are many many confounders between
smoking and shortened life expectancies
smokers typically tend to drink more
heavily and have a less healthy diet and
these light healthy diet can also lead
to them to have a shortened life
expectancy
from a different angle when people
become ill they tend to give up smoking
so this may wrongly suggest their
worsened health are actually due to they
give up smoking so there are some
reverse causation issues we have to take
into account
well ideally we probably want to run a
randomized control trials say we recruit
10 000 patients and we assign half of
them to control say they do not smoke
another half to smoking
and then we monitor their house for a
long time so that we will know if their
shortened life expectancy are really due
to smoking but this kind of randomized
control trials are neither ethical nor
practical
fortunately we've all been recruited
into an experiment when we were born
so our genes are randomly inherited from
generations to generations and they are
not confounded with any factors we have
in our life
our genes also decide how we sleep eat
and also to some degree our smoking
habits
for example that we know that uh smokers
carry one version of the gene is called
chr985
tends to smoke more heavily than those
who carry a different version
so this means carrying chroma 5 leads to
probably more like a smoking tendency
the woman is stratified patient sorry
when we stratify probably participants
or like people across the witch version
of chr 95 we find out there is no
association between their life
expectancy and smoking i'm sorry between
their life exact certain life's fantasy
and in non-smokers so this means
carrying this one particular version of
a gene cannot actually use you to have a
shortened large pregnancy there means
there's no association between carrying
chronic fiber and also shortening life's
pregnancy but when we imagine the
association between smoking and
shortening life expectancy and this is
something we can observe
this just means uh the effects between
smoking and sharpness shortened life
expectancy must immediate must be kind
of explained by carrying this version of
the gene
the mendelian randomization is the kind
of approach is trying to incorporate
genetic information and try to tell us
about the factors that influence our
health
so this is just one motivating example
so we are trying to use something else
only affect the treatment that does not
affect the outcome to conduct causal
analysis
in a more medical language we can look
at a causal diagram
in this caudal diagram we have a risk
factor say smoking and why here is the
outcome and we are interested in knowing
uh what is the causal association
between this risk risk factor and the
outcome so this parameter beta is our
interest it's our key uh key of key
parameter of interest
and because there are many many major
confounders you here so i have to i hope
to use other genetic variants as
instrumental variables to conduct causal
analysis
so typically in our body we have more
than one gene so this means we have
access to g1 to gp multiple genetic
instruments
in this case nandini randomization are
hoping to use all this information to
better estimate beta
how can we do this
in this causal diagram i am one i'm
going to make three assumptions so the
first assumption is we want to use those
genetic variants who are relevant to the
risk factors this means we only want to
use this genetic variants gg
which are associated with a risk factor
x
in other words we want to use these
causal pathways with gamma j does not
equal to zero
the second assumption is that we want to
use ggs which are independent with the
potential outcomes start with us
with a major confounders
and lastly we also assume g is also
blocked away from this potential outcome
y so there's only one valid causal
pathway which after g to x to y
under this causal diagram of course this
is one of the basic causal diagram there
are also other issues we have to focus
on for example like genetic polyatropy
this means other color pathways may not
have a cross here but this is really not
the focus of this particular talk so in
this talk i'm going to work with the
simplified uh assumptions from
maintaining randomization
in this causal diagram we can work with
a very popular structural equation
models
so we can see the outcome y can be
explained by a linear combination of my
risk factor as well as the confounded
unknown
sorry unmeasured compounders u so y
equals beta x plus beta y of u another
noise term which is independent with
everything
and then for the risk factors so the
risk factor can be explained by a linear
effect of all the genetic variance plus
the major confounders plus something
which is also independent of everything
once we have this equation in hand these
two equations in hand again our
parameter of interest is beta is the
causal effects so a simple simple
plug-in trick we can just plug in the
equation x into the equation of y let's
see what happens
so by doing a simple plug-in uh plug-in
plugging trick into between these two
equations so we find out the causal
effect of beta is simply the ratio
between this big gamma j and little
gamma j
so here in this industrial diagram the
big gamma j are the measured
associations between y and the genetic
variance and the little gamma j are the
measured associations between g and x
so when we take the ratio between these
two numbers we can have access to the
causal effects
the question is okay this looks very
simple as long as these two ratios i
know how to estimate the causal effects
the question is where we can have these
associations
uh fortunately in the past decade um the
proliferation of a genome-wide
association studies give us access to
these
to these associations these measured
associations suppose for now we have two
data sets one data sets contains the
measured associations between the
genetic variants and exposure variables
in other words we have access to these
gamma j heads along with its standard
ifs for all genetic variants
and then in another data set we call
outcome data sets we have access to the
associations between the outcome and the
genetic appearance and they are denoted
as this big gamma j
once we have this we can say okay for
each genetic variance i can simply take
the ratio between these two associations
so there i say they're all like beta j's
because we have so many different beta
j's we can always do a mental analysis
to combine them
so very popular estimator has frequently
used in dna randomization is called
inverse variance weighted estimator as
you can see here i'm just doing a
weighted combination of these different
beta j's estimated from different
genetic variants
but there's a very small problem
the question is what if some gamma js
are very very small
this means some genetic variants are
only very very weakly associated with my
risk factors in this case if you include
those genetic variables as genetic
variants as in instrumental variables
this will lead to our ivw estimator very
very unstable because beta j-hat is
going to explode
the reason i want to start with this
particular ivw estimator is because it's
so popular so nearly in all my dna
randomizations paper i saw report this
estimator so that's why i want to start
with this one
okay so the question is here i have a
very very small gamma j hat for some
genetic variants now some beta j hats
are going to explode
a common practice has been adopted in
dna randomization is a snip selection
very simple idea say i only want to use
genetic variants gamma j heads when they
are larger than some threshold some
significant threshold i only incorporate
j baron j as long as say my associations
bypass some significant threshold this
is a very nice idea right because i want
to have those stabilized beta j heads
but this common exercise actually caused
a winner's curse into our mending
randomization
it's very simple because gamma j hats
are the associations measured with ear
they are actually a random variable they
can differ across two different simple
different samples this means when gamma
j hat divided by sigma j is larger than
lambda does not mean in the population
my gamma j is also larger than this
lambda
and when this gamma j hat is actually
larger than gamma j this means our beta
g hat is going to be under out is going
to be uh underestimated once you have an
underestimated beta j the whole causal
effect is going to be underestimated as
well
that's why sometimes we report results
from mendelian randomization actually
the results you got the causal
associates you got maybe lower than the
ones actually in the population
and this one is called this is this
phenomenon is caught by the winner's
chris phenomenon
and according to my reading and this
winter's chris phenomenon is known as
one of the fundamental challenges in
median randomization with summary data
in this talk i i just want to show you
okay how severe is nandini randomization
i probably won't show you something
in real data analysis for now let's
start with the simulation study
this is a very commonly adopted
simulation study in mandani
randomization with summary data they're
very boring
so i want to skip them so you can see my
beta j sorry this is actually gamma j
it's a typo here actually follows a
truncated normal distribution so most of
them most of the genetic variance has no
association between the uh with the with
the risk factor and only a small portion
of them has association with the genetic
being oh with the risk factor and in
this simulation setup i want to show you
how severe the windows curse bias is
i will consider like a three estimators
in particular so one of them you have
already seen is called two simple median
randomization with ivw this means snip
selection and causal effect estimation
happened on the same sample so this two
simple main dna randomization estimator
has some data double use issues
and because wonders curse is really
caused by i'm using the same data for
selection and estimation happening on
the same sample a very very uh intuitive
way of avoiding this a winner's curse
phenomenon is having a different say
independent jivas data for snip
selection so this is something we call
like a free sample and dna randomization
estimator with interest variance
weighting
very simple
so this means i want to have an like a
independent data independent independent
givers which is independent exposure
data set and then on this data set on
this particular data set also measures
the association between the genetic
variants and the risk factors i conduct
snip selection i want to know which snip
have a genuine association with the risk
factors
and then on the rest of two data sets i
construct my original ivw estimator
well this three simple ivw estimate
looks actually looks very very nice but
in practice finding a third independent
devas is actually very very hot oh this
might be because the jivas are always
doing i've always done by meta analyze
so they want to incorporate more and
more snips and the largest the more that
more as many as many data as many data
sets as possible so finding a third
independent device to some degree can be
very very hot
let's look at the simulation results
now on this plot i want to show you on
the y-axis is the bias proportion which
is measured by the multi-color bias
divided by the causal effects
and then on the x-axis i will show you
the iv proportion around the cutoff
value so you can think about when more
ivs are around the cut-off value i run a
fixed significant threshold more of them
are going to be accidentally correlated
with my risk factors in this case the
winner's curse will be enhanced
uh three curves so one curve this red
curve is the two-sample median
randomization estimator and the blue
curve is a three sample mendelian
randomization estimator and the green
one looks perfect so this is our
estimator so you can see from this
results here
the difference between the three simple
median randomization estimator which is
a two simple one is really caused by the
winner's curse because there are no
difference between them
but the only difference is actually
selection for three simple mr estimator
happened on a different symbol
you can also see there is a small
observation there's a small residual
bias in the three simple then the
perfect free simple median randomization
estimator so later on i will show you
the small residual bias is caused by the
measuring air bias issues in mundane
randomization with summary statistics
now we have seen the winner's curse bias
and we have also see free simple media
randomization is not really perfect
now in this talk in the rest of probably
like um 10 minutes i will give you a
possible remedy to completely remove the
windows cross bias
well in genetic study you might have
heard women's curse phenomenon for many
many times and there are many many
approaches proposed to some degree to
overcome this issue but so far according
to my uh reading no methods can
completely remove the winner's curse
bias everything every method can do a
little bit by correction but once you
devise correction valid inference
becomes very very challenging
the difference so different from
existing approaches our approach is the
one that fully breaks the winner's curse
there's no residual bias
and on the other hand we can provide
valid statistical inference with
rigorous guarantees
now let's take a look what is the
heuristics behind our proposal
okay so this is a boring page i just
want to show you
why we have the small residue bias
uh so this is the ivw estimator uh which
can be viewed as simply regressing the
big gamma j on the little gamma j so i
will probably not go to detail here i
just want to show you there's a
measurement air bias issue in mendelian
randomization estimator on the
denominator
ideally if we want to have no bias in
our estimator the denominator should be
measured with gamma j squared instead of
gamma j hat squared just because in dna
randomization everything is measured
with randomness everything comes from a
random sample therefore the denominator
is actually much larger than the ones we
ideally want to use and this is really
caused by we're using jiva's data from a
random sample you stand up from the
population
so therefore uh to remove this uh this
small residue measurement error biasing
free simple median randomization is also
very easy so we just minus a term in a
denominator to make this estimator a
little bit larger so this is how we
actually remove the measurement error by
its issue so this is something not
proposed by us there's a very nice paper
called device inverse variance weighted
estimator this is first discovered by
them so i just want to show you some
intuitions and our estimator inherits
the same property as this particular
estimator
another thing i want to show you is the
winner's curse bias so where does the
winner's curse bias comes is actually in
the numerator in the numerator
in the numerator uh ideally when the ivw
estimator has no bias we want the
gamma hat uh conditioning and selection
have the same distribution as the
original one we hope that gamma j hat
centers on comma j
well just because the gamma j hat
distribution is have to be conditional
selection therefore the conditional
distribution no longer follows a
gaussian distribution
so our key idea of breaking the winner's
curse is to say okay things is have a
distorted distribution can we somehow
restore its normal distribution with the
correct center after selection
uh
the thing is we can
our idea is to say okay since three
simple median randomization estimator is
free of winner's cursed bias issue just
because selection happened on the
independent sample so our ideas say okay
i want to create independence i want to
create
the independence between the snip
selection and parameter estimation so
the way we do it is to say we don't do
the original snip selection procedure
anymore we want to do a randomized
selection we want to create something
fake something like called dj which is
something we call a pseudo snip risk
association measures dj follow some
gaussian distribution
and the randomized selection procedure
we do is say we want to suck a snippet j
only if gamma j hat plus zj bypass some
significant threshold
so this is a different selection
procedure but as long as your snip has a
genuine association with your risk
factor this won't
this won't actually affect your
selection because you know gamma j is
already very very large the other random
noise is still going to be selected
and this is our randomized snip
selection procedure
you might also notice i have a tuning
parameter gamma here uh ita here so our
procedure is actually not very sensitive
to the choice of eta due to the next
step i'm going to introduce so first of
all i want to create a different kind of
independence and the second step i want
to create some independence
so the way we create an independent say
here is the selection event i want to
screen out these weak ivs
and then i want to create and
gamma j head estimator which is
independent with selection and also this
initial estimator is also centered
correctly centered on gamma j
so once we have created the independence
between these two things and we are
ready to propose our final estimator but
before we do that we have to say the
initial estimator is something i
construct is purely by construction by
probability
in this case interesting may not have a
full efficiency so we want to have more
efficiency we want to more efficiently
use our data therefore we have a second
step we want to use rob localization by
projecting the initial estimator onto
the sufficient statistic of the
selection event so once we do this
there's a gamma head jrb is short for
rob equalization has the full efficiency
is also the appearance is also the
estimator which is unbiased with the
minimum appearance
once this gamma g head is constructed
this first of all is independent of the
selection second of all is also centered
correctly on gamma j we can completely
remove the winner's curse just to give
you more evidence you can see this is a
histogram of our construction
so conditioning on selection the blue
histogram shows the distorted
distribution of gamma j hat after
selection
and the uh the the yellow histogram
shows the raw black west estimator which
have a correct center and also looks
very very normal this means our
estimator can completely break the
winner's curse into sample maintaining
randomization
once we have the raw black west
estimator in hand we can just go ahead
and propose our final estimator which
you can see here have the similar format
as the ivw estimator the only difference
is that we have replaced the gamma j
with gamma j head rb
just because this raw black quest
estimator is correctly centered
conditioning on you have already
selected this particular snip
we have also removed the measurement
error bias issue by minus a small term
in the denominator
this is our final estimator
probably this is something all i want to
talk about and uh in theory in
statistical methodologies and lastly and
maybe i have one more boring page to
show just because i come from
biostatistics uh this is our theoretical
guarantees so now you can see our rivw
estimator oh the reason we name is that
as random re-randomized ivw estimator is
just because nandina randomization has
one layer of randomness because
everything is randomly inherited when we
were born our genes are randomly
inherited and now our approach really
randomized the whole selection procedure
to have two layers of randomness so
that's why we call our estimator as
re-randomized inverse variance weighted
estimator
so now this is our theoretical guarantee
we can show our estimator after
appropriate scaling converges to a
gaussian distribution and its variance
can be consistently estimated
this is all for the theory just a little
bit on demonstration in numerical
studies
uh this is uh uh we compare our approach
with again the two sample mr and the
three samplemen dna randomization also
another approach remove the measurement
error bias issues and then the last one
is called rivw estimator
so this just a few things to highlight
in this in this results so first of all
our rfw estimator is consistent
its consistency is comparable with a
three simple median randomization
estimator so it's generally free of the
winner's current spice issue
and the second thing i want to say an
rvw estimator among the ones we have
considered in this particular simulation
setup has the smallest variability with
the high detection power so you can see
the power is very very very good
this is also quite intuitive it's just
because we have conductive selection we
screen out those important snips so it's
always also probably not a surprise that
we have a high deduction power for our
estimator
and lastly
our fbw estimator has also efficiently
used information stored in the jivas
because we are free of the winner's
curse bias issue we can incorporate more
and more snips into our analysis
okay
so one more thing this is a similar
message i want to show you maybe lastly
these are probably two minutes left i
think i want to show you a real data
analysis we have done there's something
called same trait analysis same trade
analysis is a very uh simple idea to
test if our methods works in real data
really well
in the same trade analysis our risk
factor and outcome are the same thing so
we just want to know say for example if
increased bmi uh causes the increased
bmi so this means the causal effects in
real data is generally one
and these two giveaways we use to
calculate the associations between bmi
and b and minor risk factors are just uh
taken from the ie opengives projects
they're really independent give us data
sets
and we have another measurement is hdl
to hdl does the increased hdl leads to
the increased hdl so the causal effect
again equals to one
in this case we can find out our rfw
estimator
our rvw estimator among the ones which
are under comparison are the only ones
give us the genuine with a true causal
effect estimate which actually obtains
one so all other estimators tend to have
a downwards bias which is
which is in line with our analysis we
have some we have saw earlier
uh just as a quick summary
in today's talk
i have discussed the benefits of using
the daily randomization to study causal
effects and we have also seen classical
median randomization with summary data
provides biased estimates just due to
the winter's current bias and also
medical earbuds issues
and we have offered a simple remedy
called re-randomized inverse variance a
weighted estimator that fully breaks the
winner's curse as well as the management
earbuds issues
and that's all for my talk thank you
thank you very much
questions
yes
thank you jinx i have to say this is the
most clear talk i've heard about the
data randomization introduction part
thank you and so i have a question
regarding the independence so yeah i
think you have the slide showing that
the estimator is independent of the
selection yes yeah
yes yes
right here so in the first bullet point
i'm just curious why are they
independent yeah that's something you
can check in probabilities calculate
this so first of all these selection
variable gamma j plus zj follows the
gaussian distribution and the initial
estimator just gamma j hat minus gg also
follows the gaussian distribution don't
check independence just check their
correlation i see i see that's a very
interesting construction thank you okay
[Music]
other questions
yeah the theories is very good have you
tried um oh like not just the beta
should be one cases more like smoking
versus cancer you know more the
traditional cases to see whether or not
you're doing better yes we tried we
tried in the analysis in real dental
analysis we have two case studies one is
the same trait analysis correct another
one yes another one is a bmi to covet 19
severity we also found out through our
approach the causal effects are
scheduled larger so our logout's ratio
is actually higher than the ones we
usually usually believe
so on average you get more power and
averages got more power yes
thank you
[Music]
so at this meeting we have discussed um
multi-ethnic
cohorts yeah so
is that something you think you can
improve on if the
causation is not the same in different
parts of the cohort for example with
afghanistan
yeah i have to apologize for my
ignorance i don't know what is
multi-cohort study i mean if you have a
mixture of caucasians europeans with
people from elsewhere in the world from
asia and so on so uh
that's a there's a very i mean it's a
sort of goal in precision medicine
to
to treat all ethnicities
in a good way yes i i think i understand
part of the question i think that's a
very interesting angle
but one thing is we haven't saw any
mundane randomization approach works for
multiple populations
so so that's something worth
investigating and on top of that of
course there's a winner's cursed bias
component and something probably we can
improve further
yeah because i think potentially your
approach could maybe maybe do something
in that
space where emma has not been able to
work thank you thank you for the support
great and thanks again for this very
clear talk that's what we need at this
point in the meeting
[Applause]